hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
rain these [ __ ] be trying to kill me
okay so things be tripping all over the
place are these still Wonka lovely yes
they are I forgot that the amnesia chase
music was a part of that I almost
panicked for a second there alright this
is still gooped up but I have a crowbar
now well damn it stop falling apart jeez
I'm not done yet I need to get out of
here first then you can collapse alright
I'm assuming that's just meant to build
a sense of urgency but I don't feel it
quite yet
think flank Kleber dude alright did I
get it back nope
does not oh I did get it back good good
good oh good hopefully this place won't
collapse
oh is this a door that was blocked in
from the other side I'm guessing yes did
I hear something I swear I hear
something anything hello hello Skell
goodbye scold tinderboxes knock it off I
didn't mean it dary whatever recent
prison break sniffing I forgot my voice
have necessitated my barricading discrim
I wish this wasn't the case but by the
way with the prison there been acting a
little concerned spider we can say the
prisoners can be worked up into a real
frenzy to kill my man partially eaten
yesterday I request more guards be
trying to down here for the castle in
order to maintain our - down here
secondly I'm being informed that the
dreams were once again clogged with
flesh and blood in the bass he's gonna
have a contraction from now on in the
past I have ensured to act on such
inconveniences immediately however the
sickly atmosphere is conductive to
breaking the spirit of the prisoners the
air feels as L could be get with an F we
shall leave it as it is for the Tamblyn
oh you Oh
wind blowing boring okay so I have a key
a secret key this place is coming apart
I probably shouldn't leave until I find
what I came for we'll help with it what
did I go for so there was a key to the
northern prison cells we fell down
shaft ah
wait a minute okay I have a chemistry
pot now I know what I need to do I need
to dissolve the goopy remains of the my
fellow prisoners and I know I heard
something stop crying your little baby
okay so now I just need to find some
acid okay this is an exorbitant amount
of blood by-the-by still exorbitant wait
a minute what done wait a minute so I
have a chemistry pot now but no acid
there must have been yeah this is still
OOP wait a minute how did I get it
I heard that shut up man everyone wants
to get on my nerves today is everything
in there no okay
all right I guess I'm headed back down I
don't remember seeing any um acid
anywhere but I might be mistaken maybe
there was one in one of these torch it's
locked
I know maybe it it's locked wasn't I
just in there I'm just going on here oh
well I got a chemistry pot maybe the
answers will be revealed as I go further
down or maybe not or maybe I'm just lost
and going in a circle again wait could
be true
any acid in here and he acid in here no
okay let's get out of here yeah that is
quite unsettling in a lot of ways that
is still cooped up and I and no worse
for wear was that always scooped up
there no nothing in here either I
remember ah damn chase music good just
give me the heebie jeebies I know it's
specially designed to be particularly
unnerving it's locked or these lock
before I don't think so
Wow let's trigger it one more time for
good old-fashioned aah oh wow okay
what was that all about it was down here
the brazen bull was here but I have no
reason to like that oh god I cannot see
a damn thing
okay it's gotta be something down here
than I'm missing I still wonder what
this secret key is for or did I already
check those and I'm just being stupid
probably okay there's gotta be something
down here maybe this is metal bucket
stained with red blood doesn't help me
at all doesn't help me at all
that was wait I was supposed to get
something from down here
I know I know it wants me to get acid
and somehow hearted mixture of body
tissue and blood I know but I can't
Pierce it with my chipper
I can't crowbar it can't secret kid
can't ya
I musta missed something I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot I'm an idiot oh okay
so I must be missing something there
must be acid in one of these unless I'm
not thinking about it correctly maybe I
should just jump from a high point and
smash through it with brute oh that's
right how did I miss this room I thought
the door was locked
I just wanted the doors locked okay
whatever oh come on give me something
give me some some oh wait no here that's
right Boop
yes that would have been easily missed
if I hadn't been experienced in amnesia
before oh there was a whole pool of acid
that people dipped it in I'm sorry I'm
terribly stupid you were all probably
yelling at me like that I don't rum of
action hearts tomorrow I'm quite stupid
as the answer yes northern prison cells
key and now this place is going to hell
no no oh no oh the room is filling up
with blood that doesn't seem good that
is quite concerning that's quite a
plumbing problem if that's happening oh
my god super agility all yay I get out
of my wet ward
ah ah ha ha - bro - bro
oh yeah - Pro supper was a minute it's
not like that would kill me I mean it's
just blood right couldn't I just swim in
it and ride it up to the top I don't
know what I'm flying in such a hurry but
I will comment that this is an
extraordinarily cool sequence you don't
see something like this in amnesia
custom stories like ever this is really
quite creative
very much so anything over there okay
here we go
I find myself abnormally trusting of
Ulrich's elaborate intuitions and
astonishingly they've been accurate so
far ah oh my back
oh oh oh it flew me forward by the sheer
pressure of blood
alright whatever what was that what the
hell is that how about I go to hell I
was wondering where he was because I had
been previously guarded by a monster and
then the monster suddenly disappears
Yeah right who's crying
like I've said many time before we all
got problems stop being such a baby
about it oh that's the secret key
kliklak Lou Rick's confidence is
reassuring I feel overwhelmed by the
possibility of my escape from this
madness as though I've been imprisoned
in these holes much longer than I
actually have okay so now it's dark they
still haven't given me a lantern I have
a feeling that they're not gonna give me
one ever they want me to just wander in
the darkness I mean that's one thing
take away some people's normal point of
safety oh no here's oil and a lantern
never mind
I thought it was gonna be different but
I spoke way too soon ax I barely spoke
Sassoon at all okay so I need it's not
in working order
it needs coal oh yes it needs cool the
coal engine will never go out of style
it'll always be
when Guardium Livia song Livia song okay
clock with a simple lock hibiscus key
secret key well what the hell maybe I
could fashion something to pick this
lock with um I don't know how about a
hammer and maybe a long cylindrical
crowbar God darn I really can't be
kidding me right it's locked with a
simple lock you're gonna pick it with
all of your lock picking experience
instead of bashing through it okay
whatever logic thrown to the wind as we
search for something that can be used as
'm okay for some reason those sound what
is that sounds like rocks tumbling but
at the same time I swear I hear a voice
in it oh I need to put this on the
machine good blue ski flam dingo yes
doesn't even need coal it's too proud
for coal or something back there none
all right so the machine's working again
what does that mean for me does it mean
anything for me
should I start using my lantern no these
are all silly questions what am i doing
where am I going why am i me what am i
doing with myself all these questions I
do not know the answer to why was that
machinery needed to be run why can't I
find a pic for this stupid thing all of
these great questions empty bucket no
okay I need to find something else that
machinery must have led to something but
I just don't know what it was we could
have possibly been used for I didn't
even see anything over here that
required machinery is there something
I'm missing there's got to be something
I'm missing here right I mean what's the
point of this here throw something in
here I guess Wow I really didn't expect
that to work
hahahaha you're kidding me right what is
this
what hahaha
and then I yeah yeah wow that is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen in my
life
but yeah okay now I got haha now I got
shards of metal that I could use for a
lockpick wow I can't believe that worked
that was like the weakest string of
logic in the world okay going the other
way God all right
I do not wish to go slow right now I
wish to go fast
now Thank You moose man ah if you guys
know me you guys were probably like oh
he's gonna be stuck on this forever oh I
can't believe oh he's so oh oh I wasn't
doing that at that I was that was you
guys at me when I get that and you go
whoa that was my impression for you guys
yeah there's a moose man around let's
see if he's really that scary I'm gonna
say new kliklak I should probably nude I
got hahaha where I come from you can't
see me if I can't see him hey buddy
you're not gonna bash your way into here
I guess you didn't really see me going
on buddy
how about it hey friend be real sneaky
but I didn't say anything you saw
everything didn't you nope
ha ha ha ha well oh man I love [ __ ]
around with the moose man ooh oh god
he's gonna bash his way in here isn't he
you don't hear [ __ ]
why did I do that I still huh
the moose man isn't one of my leaves
favorite of all but like he's like
somehow he's like the perfect
combination of sounded like everything
you didn't hear [ __ ] haha
Jesus balls oh hell no thank you I don't
wanna go away I sure Rock okay that was
stupid house dumb of me oh jeez
I actually have to be a little sneaky
about this I don't even know what I'm
looking for in these rooms I haven't
found anything so far let me just take a
quick gander did you do something under
the bed baby
under the bed I can't even move the bed
Murdaugh no nothing let's not run in
let's not run straight into the moose
man that's my least favorite activity
what was that no you do not you did not
see a thing
you did not see a damn thing all right
what am I looking for what am I looking
for the strings of logic in this uh-huh
cuss of star not very fruitful okay
nothing there it's gotta be some else
here
some reason for the season
oh okay hang on let me check this one
real quick that look wall oh oh oh wait
no what the hell or whatever yeah secret
door
oh oh Oscars relic one of three oh yeah
hey 50 great birthday I just thought I
would should mention that I can no
longer remember who exactly who I am and
so I would like to take this opportunity
to name my job from now on I shall we
know you dr. Williams no fn- documented
public don't give me a name do the work
train tik nine remember did a count but
know who I am okay
document catalog British Museum lucky I
might even open to own that Museum
excellent condition combination coffee
in history okay I haven't written
anything for lesser team day playing
mummies Jam
nothing interesting having you today or
uh starting to get worried who is
cleaning the kitchen
I wasn't plan continuing this piece but
maybe these last words I feel my end is
coming no one has been around to serve
me food of water on the bright side one
of the regular guards often likes to
rave that I'll be transferred to the
torture chambers soon says I'm gonna get
the saw and so maybe hopefully no one
will be around to steal me away for that
either
overhearing prison talk eating rats
looking water from the stone of their
cells I would rather starve that's if
the odor drifting in from the kitchen
doesn't kill me first
all the kitchen fully I could clean it
well Oscar you're a weirdo stop being so
strange I'm gonna steal your artifacts
and with them I shall open this museum
in your honor that's okay I think that
oh you can see daylight why didn't she
try to get out that way okay I'm just
gonna stop in here for a bit step right
in here and I'm gonna end this right
here in the closet so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will say
in the next video
Oh
bud
ah
Oh